here boy College gonna be a ruin I come
from a family of brewing collegiate
experience I think I'm just looking
forward to everything in general having
that experience I think it's something
that really just enriches your life and
I think anything for me to go to college
with other undergraduate students find
people that are studying the same thing
as many people that aren't you just meet
like a more diverse group of people and
that's what I'm really excited for I'm
also just excited to be a college
student you know you're learning have
you picked out any classes or anything I
am taking my classes this weekend but I
know I want to major in political
science that's such a change from what
you're doing now why why this shift well
I've been acting my whole life so I feel
like for me it wouldn't it just I feel
like I should have knowledge in another
subject because the industry is so you
can't predict what's gonna happen I
could be working now and then never work
again the next 10 years so I thought
it's important to have knowledge and
another subject that you like that you
can have as a plan in the future any
thoughts I mean you said you're gonna
study political science any thoughts on
this coming election I absolutely hate
Donald Trump I just like to be honest I
wish we had better candidates I do I'm
pretty disappointed that this is what a
that this is that these are the
candidates now like we've come so far
yet the candidates don't really reflect
the amazing strides